good morning or evening or wherever it
is where you are wherever you're
happening to watch this movie anyway
I've been requested to do a playlist on
probability and I think that's an
excellent idea so I will start doing a
playlist on probability so let's do a
playlist on probability probability so a
good place to start probability I don't
do videos on spelling probability so
what what is it and I think all of us
have kind of a sense of it you know and
very informally and as far as I can tell
there actually isn't a formal definition
of what a probability is there are kind
of several almost formal competing
definitions so it just in our everyday
life you know if the weatherman says
there's a 50% chance of rain chance of
rain the next day he's essentially
giving a probability he's saying that
well there's a couple of ways that you
could interpret it interpret the 50%
probability it could be that he's he if
if a hundred percent was that he is sure
there's rain tomorrow and 0% is that he
is not sure that there's rain tomorrow
that 50% kind of means well he's he's
kind of neutral between those two
possibilities so you could one
definition could be how much how
strongly you believe how strongly you
believe and and this is actually a
there's a whole school of probability
where they where they view probability
like this this is called the Bayesian
Xand we'll go into that more and
actually when we do easy problems all of
these things kind of are the same thing
but later on we'll we'll see what the
difference is another way of
interpreting this and this is kind of
the the frequentist school of thought is
if I were to have the data that this or
if the weatherman had this data that he
has right now as far as you know where
the clouds are and you know what the
barometer reads and you know where the
moon is and all of the data given all of
the data that he has when he has that
same exact data a hundred times 50 times
or 50% of those times there will be rain
so you can almost view it as given the
data he has if you had that data a
hundred times or if you
that if you're able to run this
experiment a hundred times although
that's very unlikely that you would have
that exact same of same number of data
points you know whether Mars is in the
right place and the Sun is flaring you
know it's very unlikely you have those
exact same and circum you know and you
know you know the butterfly effect one
butterfly can affect the wind patterns
across the ocean so it's very unlikely
that you could perform that experiment a
hundred times but what the weatherman
could be saying is well if I could if I
did have data identical to this a
hundred times fifty of those times or
fifty percent of the time we would have
rain the next day so that's that's the
50% of experiments 50% of experiments
with same I guess you could say
measurable initial conditions same
initial I'm kind of doing this on the
fly so don't you know don't take this as
gospel but it I think it'll give you the
sense with same initial conditions would
result in rain and you can they're
almost the same thing and but we'll see
later that you know this frequentist I
attend to view the world kind of like
this but there are a lot of
circumstances where you really it's it's
hard to say that you could perform that
same exact experiment over again for
example if someone said in 2003 there's
a 50% chance or there's an 80% chance
that Saddam Hussein has weapons of mass
destruction that I think would and that
would be a probability you know you'd
have these CIA analysts who aren't being
influenced by their bosses saying hey
after all the data we see we can't be
sure but we think there's an 80% chance
and that's what they would be in this
camp right because you really couldn't
perform that experiment a hundred times
there haven't been a hundred times or a
thousand times or a large number of
times where you had that exact same set
of circumstances where you had you know
a guy with a big mustache in the Middle
East you know kind of giving the
runaround for weapons inspectors anyway
so let's move on I think this is this is
very subtle but it gives you the
difference between these two things or
it's quite subtle but it I think it
gives you a good nice framework for what
probability
is so let's just do a little bit of
notation and actually I'm going to I
actually looked at up on Wikipedia and
and they had one definition maybe wasn't
Wikipedia was maybe another website and
actually I think you do see this
definition of lot where they say you
know the probability and you know
sometimes it's written is probability of
a sometimes it's just written as P of a
so the probability of a occurring is
equal to the number of events or or the
events the events in which a is true
over total number of events and this for
the most part can be a good definition
but I'll show you one place where I
think it's a little bit more squirmy so
if I told you that you know I'm going to
flip a coin and actually even better
let's let's say let's roll a dice and
let's say I say the probability I'm you
know I'm not I'm going straight to more
difficult things so let's say the
probability of an even number well let's
use this definition that they gave well
what's the probability that this event
is true well let's see what are all the
numbers I could get I could get a 1 2 3
4 5 6 is just a normal die it's not one
of those Dungeons & Dragons dice so what
what are the number of events where we
get an even number where this is true
where even is true see 2 4 6 those are
all the situations where we get even is
true so there are three or even is true
and then what is the total number events
where we could get one of 6 numbers so
there's 6 total and that equals 1/2 and
that also equals 50% right we know how
to convert fractions to percentages and
this is right this is completely right
but the only time where you can really
apply this and in most of what you'll do
in school and things you can apply this
but this assumes that all of the events
are equally likely to occur right you
could have had a dice or die
I forget how to say the plural or the
singular you could have that situation
where
maybe you know the 6-sided is weighted a
little bit more you know someone sanded
it down so it's more likely to have a
three or something and in that case you
wouldn't be able to use this definition
so I'm going to modify this definition
although I don't know if it's
traditionally modified this is one
possible events events in which a is
true divided by let's say equally
probable equally probable events in
which a is true divided by equally
probable equally probable total events
so in order for this to hold true
each of these six circumstances have to
have an exact equal chance of occurring
and we're going to do maybe in this
video actually probably not in this I
only have three minutes left
but in this series I'll show you the
situations where you know will will have
an unfair dice or die or it will have a
you know a set of circumstances where
all of each of the total number events
they're not equally probable so that's
why I want you to become a little bit
wary of of this situation so with that
said let's let's do a couple of
probability problems that maybe give you
a little bit more intuition for for
whoops work for what's going on here in
the world of probability so if I'm
flipping a dice and I said well what's
the probability of heads that's pretty
easy and we could use that definition
and it's a completely fair dice we could
use that definition to say well how many
what are the total number event so I
could get heads or tails right so
there's two total events and the
probability of getting heads that's one
of the events so there's a 1/2
probability the way I like to think of
it so we don't have to use that previous
definition is if I were to conduct this
experiment if I were to conduct this
experiment a hundred times what
percentage of those times am I likely to
get hits and then I would say well
there's 50% of the time I would get
heads and the reason why you know I
could make a symmetry argument that it's
just as likely to go on heads is it is
the tails there's no reason why I would
expect 51 heads or 49 tails
although that could happen but there's
no reason I could expect it heads and
tails are equally likely they're just
different words for different sides of a
coin that's equally likely to fall on
either side
anyway so what what would be the likely
let's say I'm going to now flip a coin
twice and it's the same coin so I'm
going to flip it and I'm going to pick
it up and I'm gonna flip it again and so
what's the probability that I get I'll
call it heads heads so that's the
probability that I get heads on the
first flip and then heads on the second
flip well look of it this way if on the
first flip we already know that we have
a 50% chance or 1/2 chance on the first
flip right so let's think of it of the
the frequentist philosophy so if I were
to do this a hundred times right fifty
of the times I would get heads let's
call that on the first flip and of
course fifty of the times I would get
tails on the first flip right now we're
at this state of the universe and now we
do the experiment over again right so of
these 50 times of these in it you know
50 times what what percentage of the
times is the next flip going to be heads
again well we could say you know it's
going to be another 50% chance or you
could say well it took us in 50 tries
the first one was heads and then of
those 50 50 percent are going to be
heads again so we get 25% I just
multiplied these two numbers and of
course to get heads and then tails would
be 25% chance heads heads heads tails
and then this is tails heads tails heads
I'm going to confuse tail heads is 25%
and then tails tails of 25%
anyway I'm rushing it because I'm 25
seconds over I'll continue this in the
next video